hey guys I'm Gary Vaynerchuk Gary Benny  Chucky the fast-talking irreverent  business guru who calls himself a serial  entrepreneur I'm a businessman  entrepreneur Oh  four-time New York Times best seller a  guy that loves to give keynotes no [ __ ]  your product blow you nerd stop watching  lost you need to bet on your strengths  and don't give a [ __ ] about where you  suck at yeah I curse a little bit when  you [ __ ] subscribe and on this channel  you're gonna get my soup or show me  askgaryvee show  hi Gary hello Gary Vee hey Gary smart  stupid on this episode I have a guest  you keep asking questions I'll keep  answering them and daily be turning into  a few things because today and so  understand these deductions maple how  are you  we're putting out real fire she does  intense and if you subscribe right now  subscribe now you're gonna make me so  goddamn happy  so can you owe me at Gary at vaynermedia  not later right now you would make my  life so